hey folks welcome to the dark horse
podcast live stream number 100 something
is it 119 no that's right it's 100
something 100 something i knew it yeah
it's 118
118 118. which reminds me for 119 we'll
be coming to you early so in less than a
week but we don't know exactly when
sometime on saturday next week very
slightly less than a week yeah yeah yeah
i'm coming to you early so we'll get
back to you on what time that will be
but we will uh
we will be
fresh and you should be sharp because
it's going to be that kind of podcast
and well who knows really
at some point soon and it kind of looks
like it might be sooner than i was
expecting we're actually going to have a
dark horse site
where we can put announcements like that
so if for for whatever reason of keeping
your sanity you don't happen to be on
twitter which seems to be the only place
that we ever announce these things it's
also up on the youtube channel of course
but um you could you could go there and
uh and find whether or not we are
off for a week or doing something
different in terms of timing anyway next
week dark horse iron sight
will we yes are you sure of course it's
a dog whistle of some kind i have no
idea what kind of course but
if you're that kind of so i was spelling
sight differently but okay yeah
no no
oh no you were weren't you yeah yeah
yeah yeah in my heading site yeah yeah
well and website right well i'm thinking
website is like a building site it's
like a
version you were talking about a totally
different kind of site where yeah who
knows i see
yeah okay uh this week we're going to
talk a little bit about mask mandates
and how they have lifted where we live
as of today
uh
i
last week
had been sent an excerpt from the road
to wigan pier by george orwell is his
1937 book
and i read an excerpt which i found
astounding and was so intrigued by what
i looked into about the book that this
week i read the book mostly i listened
to the book but uh and i and i got a
tiny
tiny tiny little copy of it i don't
expect it to come so small but
uh it's tiny font too it's like
i don't know like eight point font
anyway um i want to share some more of
orwell's ruminations on socialism for us
to talk about this week it does strike
me that you and i are in a position to
navigate this for civilization can we
agree that listening to a book is
reading a book it seems to me that that
counts
it does count
but it is a completely different
experience for for you know i for some
people
uh
right so this this could be a riff for a
whole episode of course yes i it 100
counts uh for me i just end up doing a
lot of walking this week and i was
listening to it um
while i was walking but every time
i would hear something that i wanted to
take a note of like
how do i do that and so it was it was
much more tedious frankly and so i had
this tiny tiny little book um and then i
also have a pdf copy which was easier to
search um but harder to know
it just
i said both because i actually did do
both and i won't remember it if it just
comes in my ears unless i take a note at
the time whereas uh for you it's
somewhat the opposite well i'm not
arguing that they're the same they're
not the same for me either
for whatever reason even given my uh
you know visual
um oddities
i still get a very visual memory of
where something is if i read something
on paper and i go looking for it later i
know roughly you know which side of the
book it's on what place on the page so
you know i have that experience too my
sense is if somebody says you know
1984 have you read it and you listen to
it yeah the answer is yes yeah um if you
saw the movie the answer is no
absolutely yeah if if the text as it was
written by the author has come into your
head
um either through your eyes or through
your ears then you have effectively read
it
yeah all right um settled so we're going
to talk a little bit a bit about orwell
on socialism and vegetarians and
feminists and
he's a weirdo he is i like he he's he is
deep and my god did he die too young he
died in his late 40s
tuberculosis uh anyway uh we're going to
talk a little bit about sars kobe 2
because what we don't we
well there are forces that would prefer
that we cut it out but well i well i'm
one of them i wish that we could oh me
too me too but uh yeah we will get to
why we can't yeah yeah yeah um we're
gonna talk just a little bit about
de-transitioning in general i don't uh i
just de-transitioning from having
transitioned
uh
using medical and using surgical
hormonal techniques to
appear to be the sex that you are not
today is
i've now forgotten
this d trans awareness day and you know
in general i don't like these you know
days weeks months that get um described
as this is the day in which you have to
think about these things uh but um there
are some events that are happening today
and i want to talk a little bit just a
little bit about
about that um
we probably won't end up getting to the
diet of snakes this week um but uh
there's some research that when we don't
get to it this week i will then say
let's talk next week about the diet of
snakes because that's something i've
been thinking about and uh i have a
question about it about the diet of
snake so either we'll get there this
week or next week but uh i have a
question to ask you about well given how
much else was going on and uh that i
only uh skimmed the research paper in
question once and it went down a few
rabbit holes snake holes even maybe uh
about snakes go down rabbit holes right
exactly yeah um
i did i did not
spend probably enough time yet with the
with the research
uh
to to talk a lot but uh bring your
a-game
this is uh trash talking for biologists
it's a great whole different thing
um all right so
uh announcements first announcements
we uh we've been doing we've been on a
couple of other people's podcasts uh
this week and we'll be in the next few
weeks again about yeah some really great
ones and we'll you know we'll announce
when those come out we did a we started
doing a really bad job of announcing all
the podcasts that we were doing for the
book uh because we did um you know many
dozens of them in the few months after
the book
this book hunter gatherers guide the
21st century came out and um
i mean like i don't even know if we
announced
um being on andre yang's podcast or
jordan peterson's and you know we just
we started to do a very poor job of
talking about it but now now there's few
enough now that um
specifically uh well both of the
conversations we had this week were
excellent so um we encourage
you to look for those and we'll announce
them when they come out but also to pick
up the book and and take a look at it at
it we specifically were talking a fair
bit about uh the medicine chapter this
week the evolution of medicine and um
how it is that we can
keep ourselves healthy in a uh in a
world that seems hell-bent on keeping us
not healthy
i will also just add um i think you and
i both have a kind of uncomfortable
relationship with uh
self-promotion or anything that looks
like it and i think this is good i think
frankly you know as a scientist you're
not supposed to be a self-promoter of
course as we talked about last week the
culture of uh pursuing of grants and all
turns everybody into a salesman but
especially as the world
of people who
would like you to stop talking about
things you're talking about is accusing
you of
all manner of grifterism uh it makes it
particularly hard to
remember to say oh by the way we were on
this that in the other podcast check
them out
um so anyway
maybe uh
we are in a new era
are we
well yes i'm not i'm not promising it's
a better era but i do believe we are in
a new era okay um i'm not sure what the
implications of that are
i think the implications of that are the
president of ukraine is very handsome
and dances well and we are therefore
supposed to be in favor of uh invading
uh to drive russia out
there are a few too few pronouns in that
sentence for me to know exactly who's
who all we're in the favor in favor of
invading but uh
uh invading ukraine in its own defense i
think is the uh
conventional wisdom okay
uh
do you want to go there because i
thought we were still doing
announcements oh well yeah i guess that
doesn't qualify um we will the dark
horse podcast will not be invading
ukraine we
you're looking at me like i don't know
why we're here at all
seem right
we are on youtube and odyssey and um and
for those of you who are listening later
uh we also um are up on spotify but
right now if you're if you're watching
uh chat is live on odyssey you can ask
your questions at uh
darkhorsesubmissions.com
once again i will i in
unfortunately it seems that i need to
say this we don't get to all the
questions we don't um say that we would
we don't claim that we'll get to all the
questions so if you ask a question you
are
asking and hope that we get to it but um
but we do not and so um you are not
you're not paying for a guaranteed uh
service in that regard
um
our patreons continue to continue to
come along with some um with some
enthusiasm they both provide access to
the darkhorse community which at the
moment is housed on a discord server
that is probably going to change at some
point soon we will keep you updated with
exactly where that community is going to
go
you can get uh
merchandise with direwolves and epic
tabbies and digital book burnings and
such at store.darkworspodcast.org
find
my weekly writings at
naturalselections.subtech.com
uh this week i reprised my what if we're
wrong
essay that was published in ariel uh
some 10 months ago along with a fairly
long preamble about uh why we still need
to be thinking about this because it
seems to me that almost no one who
needed to hear that essay actually
listened the first time around and
without further ado
with some help from the cats
we have three sponsors this week
as we as we usually do at this point as
always we're very grateful uh for them
and to them and brett is going to start
us off yes uh all form sofas is our
first sponsor
uh they are a company that makes
absolutely terrific custom sofas what
makes the sofa terrific for a fraction
of the cost of traditional sofas you can
customize size layout fabric and color
they do arm chairs and love seats all
the way up to an eight seat sectional
and you can start small and buy more
seats later on without needing to get a
whole new sofa all form sofas are
delivered directly to your home free and
fast and assembly is easy and i can tell
you that it is i just assembled my
second one
we've got a beautiful sectional all-form
sofa in whiskey leather it's soft and
supple and warm unlike a lot of leather
we all pile on it to watch movies some
evenings it looks gorgeous and is
incredibly inviting and comfortable a
rare combination
we like it so much that we've just
gotten a second one as i strangely
mentioned a paragraph ago also some
listeners asked if all form holds up to
pets why yes it does the leather that
all form uses is 20 thicker than typical
furniture leather and shows nowhere
despite the fact that both cats and dogs
lie on the couch many evenings
absolutely nowhere so far
if you prefer fabric all form fabrics
are three and a half times more durable
than the industry standard for heavy
duty fabrics so their fabrics are going
to hold up really well with pets also
finally they offer a forever warranty
literally forever
to find your perfect sofa check out
allform.com
darkhorse all form is offering 20 off
all orders for our listeners at
allform.com darkhorse that's
a-l-l-f-o-r-m dot-com slash darkhorse
our second sponsor this week uh
listeners will be well familiar with
vivo barefoot we've had um we've run ads
from them for the last several weeks and
uh
man it seems to correlate with me
hearing more and more from people who
are you know writing in to tell me about
something else or to you know don't have
appreciation to also say and i just got
my first pair of vivo barefoot so um
we're we're super pleased when we hear
that because these shoes really um
really do make a difference they really
do feel like they are a fix
for so much of what ails the modern foot
they are shoes made for feet most shoes
are made for someone's idea of what feet
should be and be constrained by and
usually that someone doesn't actually
know feet or what they can do vivo
barefoot in contrast knows feet vevo
barefoot isn't driven by fashion but man
oh man are these shoes a revelation we
love them they're beyond comfortable the
tactile feedback from the surface as
you're walking on is amazing they cause
no pain at all because there are no
pressure points forcing your feet into
odd positions
our feet are the products of millions of
years of evolution and so strangely are
yours
humans evolve to walk move and run
barefoot but modern shoes that are
overly cushioned and strangely shaped
have negatively impacted foot function
and are contributing to a health crisis
one in which people move less than they
might in part because their shoes make
their feet hurt
vivo barefoot shoes are designed wide to
provide natural stability thin to enable
you to feel more and flexible to help
you build your natural strength from the
ground up foot strength increases by 60
in a matter of months just by walking
around at them the number of people
wearing vivo barefoots is growing it's
an odd little club easily recognizable
because the shoes are a little unusual
looking once people start wearing these
shoes they don't seem to stop go to
vivobarefoot.com darkhorse to get an
exclusive offer of 20 off additionally
all new customers get a hundred day free
trial so you can see if you love them as
much as we do that's
v-i-v-o-b-a-r-e-f-o-o-t
dot com slash darkhorse
and our final sponsor of the week is
public goods
public goods was one of our very first
sponsors last year and we are as pleased
with them now as when we first tried
their products public goods can simplify
your life as a one-stop shop for
everyday essentials their ingredients
are carefully sourced high quality and
affordable
public goods has coffee and tea grains
and oils like olive and avocado they've
got castile soap trash bags and
essential oils they have spices and
extracts like vanilla and almond
vinegars pastas dishware and glassware
there is so much of public goods to make
a meal including the materials to serve
it on
public goods products have great design
too the aesthetic is simple and clean
and there are no garish colors
they care about health and
sustainability public goods products are
largely free of harmful ingredients and
additives and the ingredients are
ethically sourced
finally their subscription service is
efficient and simple and easy to use
public goods members can buy all of
their premium essentials in one place it
really is an everything store
so if you're looking for a replacement
for the everything store you currently
use consider public goods for dark horse
listeners we have the following offer
receive 15 off your first public goods
order with no minimum purchase they are
so confident that you will absolutely
love their products and come back again
and again that they are going giving you
15 to spend on your first purchase with
no minimum
go to publicgoods.com darkhorse forward
slash darkhorse i never say
i'm never consistent about the forward
slash and slash
yeah
i think everyone knows what direction
the slash goes though yeah i agree go to
publicgoods.com forward slash darkhorse
or use code darkhorse at checkout that
is p u b l i c g l-i-c-g-o-d-s
dot com forward slash dark horse to
receive 15 off your first order
again we think we thank our sponsors
very much
okay you want to start by talking about
the lifting of the mask mandates here in
oregon and i think across the entire
west coast yes um
i mean i think maybe it makes sense to
point out uh
winter is leaving god yeah um here in
the pacific northwest it seems to have
just kind of given up well today so i
was out walking today and i saw a lot of
things
apropos the mask mandates just gorgeous
out and according to my phone it's going
to start raining before we're done live
streaming today and it's never going to
stop
i like it's just gonna be raining
forever well and our spring rains aren't
like that you know rain that we're
famous for here where it just kind of
drizzles all the time now the spring
rains can be tumultuous yes they can be
intense yeah um so question for you i
know you and i haven't talked about what
you saw on your walk this morning our
mask mandate ended today yep um
so
that is something that will mean very
little to people in some parts of the
country where even where they've had
mass mandates people haven't necessarily
been adhering to them but in the pacific
northwest they absolutely have and
um it has been
uh oppressive now i will you know there
are certainly probably people who have
joined us
more recently in our in our trajectory
of live streams who won't know where we
started on this so we will revisit some
of that but what you saw today as you
walked around any difference between
what you would have seen today and a
week ago
yes
um
inside so i went to a market to pick up
some
meat and such for dinner um and in the
market there were still a few people
masked but almost no one uh was was at
this point and of course a week ago
everyone was every last night everyone
was and but outside
uh where for a for a long time now most
people have not been masked although at
a moment i think i mentioned this in the
live stream at some point last
summer maybe i don't remember exactly
what time of year it was but i was
walking actually in the very same park i
was walking today by the river
um unmasked alone and a lady yelled at
me about you know
saving people's lives and not being
selfish
and i thought at the time man are people
confused could lord are people confused
about what it is what it takes to um
actually um do your job as a citizen and
and be responsible because thinking for
yourself is actually a hell of a lot
more important than virtue signaling
with something that doesn't help anyone
um but um outside today actually i did
not detect a change and maybe maybe you
would expect that there is still
um i would say now actually inside and
outside is a match there's maybe 10
percent of the people who are still
walking around masked
but you know we went out to dinner last
night and asked the waitress um you
looking forward you're looking forward
to this
and we'd asked
another uh another weight person a week
or two ago and um he had said nah i
don't really need it you know you know
it's fine take it or leave it right and
this waitress last night was like oh my
god i am going to cut this thing into
little pieces as soon as i can and never
wear it again so you know people are
having different responses to uh
to this seemingly endless experience of
putting fabric on your face yeah uh so
anyway yeah i think it's it i wish i had
thought to predict that the
uh inside environment would start
looking like the outside environment
because basically the outside
environment are people who are mask
focused and have been doing this
voluntarily you know
uh since the mask phenomenon began now
ironically the massachusetts well here
and elsewhere too but we talked in you
know spring of 2020 when they were
closing down beaches they were closing
down parks they were basically
concentrating people into small spaces
to you know help reduce the spread of
disease never made sense um but there
were signs up once the parks reopened um
and you know the beaches i'm talking
about were in california i don't
remember to the degree there were
beaches closed in oregon but um
once the parks reopened which is insane
um but you know we have some very big
you know hundreds of acres parks here in
uh in portland there were signs up that
said you absolutely must wear a mask
right and i never i never did i refused
to but at that point i was i would be
the only one on the trail without a mask
and i mean i remember a couple people
leapt out of my way you know in order to
you know reduce their chances of
contracting something from you know
outside
so so there was an expectation here for
a while yes
there was and so i want to revisit where
we've come from um because uh frankly in
going back to find photographs to remind
myself of where we
came from in the pandemic uh you know i
knew all of this but it was jarring
actually to see some of the photographs
from the beginning so zach do you want
to begin to show those and i'll describe
them for people who are just listening
um so these are photographs i believe
these are from march of 2020. two years
ago two years ago um so
just to revisit heather and i were in
the amazon finishing the first draft of
our book and heard about novel
coronavirus for the first time as our
phones came awake after
uh being in complete isolation where
there was no service of any kind so that
was january that was january um so we
returned and the story of uh novel
coronavirus which became uh sars kobe 2
and kovid
marched on so what this is a picture of
here
some of you will remember that early
dark horse episodes were not live
streams they were all discussions
between me and somebody uh in person
and they were in a different place
we built this studio into my office as
covid forced us out of the studio that
we were renting in downtown portland and
so this is too soon right this
is a photograph zach and i recaptured
everything we could from the studio
downtown
in a mad rush we were literally going
into the building at midnight so we
wouldn't interact with people because
nobody knew how this thing spread and
how dangerous it was i think it was
literally i'm just looking at the
calendar like we are literally two years
to the day from the last day that zach
was in school the following day was
toby's last day of school and then that
weekend is when you guys
emptied out the studio so the kids were
thrown out of school on mass
zach and i
took the dark horse studio and took
every piece that would move and brought
it home
[Music]
and started going to the hardware store
to get the kinds of things necessary to
make the studio work so like the
interior of asana
right like the materials from the
interior of asana cabinets and the like
all right so go ahead here an image
okay so at this time there was a
hoarding of and i don't want to say
hoarding i think that's actually the
wrong term people were stocking up on
materials not knowing what was coming
and actually i don't think they were
wrong in this regard we have now seen
supply chain issues yes they were
delayed but of course the idea that we
were in a unstable situation and that
one couldn't guarantee that staples were
going to be available was very much in
the air i thought all the supply chain
issues were due to putin's invasion of
ukraine is that not right no because of
time's arrow oh yeah yeah that's right
right right right right it's funny how
no one in the mainstream media seems to
oppose yeah the inflation also turns out
to have been well underway before that
yeah yeah all right uh go advance uh so
that was beans that were uh out of stock
interestingly people
spotted that uh you know black beans uh
were the right thing but there were lots
of other beans they left on the shelves
yeah lentils were almost always
consistently available actually good to
know and actually i didn't include a
picture here but i had a picture of the
peanut butter section
where people have not spotted just what
a good staple that is
so you could buy peanut butter even if
you couldn't buy beans this is
surprising to me you got a whole bunch
of dr bronner's on the bottom shelf
that's castile soap that stuff saves
forever you can do it use it for almost
anything you want to clean yeah yeah no
the deeper you read into that bottle the
more things you discover it's good for
it's um
there's maybe a little evangelism there
but okay um oh yeah
dude was a little out there but you know
here we got hand sanitizer has been uh
ransacked now notice
um hand sanitizer didn't actually turn
out to be important here but we all
thought it was going to be very
plausibly so now hand sanitizer is good
stuff and a lot of infectious disease
that we spread around colds and flu and
the like um is likely very sensitive to
it so i don't resent the bias towards
hand sanitizer that we've moved to but
i
we all remember
the uh the craze around
isopropyl alcohol which you couldn't get
and um hand sanitizer which turned out
to be more or less irrelevant to covet
yep
okay advance one more
now here this is a line
out the door
at the local gun shop right people were
hoarding now i got to find a better term
people were stocking up on guns and even
more importantly ammunition and it was
resulting in a store that would never
typically have a line having a line out
the door i wrote a little bit about this
uh for unheard where i discussed the
question of the second amendment and
what role um
it may actually be playing but anyway
that's the local gun store and the the
line that existed there can you go one
more
and here you can see a wall of
ugly duckling guns that people didn't
really want
but you can see how many spaces are
empty on that wall right as people are
buying now the thing that was really in
short support was ammunition that's
that's a wall that normally would have
been full every spot would have had a
gun and um and it got it dwindled more
than that
um
but it was it was the ammunition that
that just simply wasn't available
anywhere much like hand sanitizer okay
advance one more
all right now here is why i was going
back
to look for photos
um i was one of the first people to mask
in portland i was so early that i was
the only person at the hardware store
zach and i were
getting materials to build the studio
here
i was going in masked with those are
safety glasses with a little bit of
reading glasses
in the yeah and they have side flanges
yeah and i had a technique and the basic
idea was nobody knew how this thing
transmitted at that point
everyone was talking about fomites and
very high cfrs and all this so it stood
to reason that a mask was a good idea
even if nobody else was wearing them
maybe especially if nobody else is
wearing them it stood to reason that
because many viruses do get in through
your eyes that having safety glasses on
was a good idea
and in order that they didn't interact
badly with my reading glasses i got the
reading glasses built in i also uh used
cloth gloves you could buy like 10
gloves for five ten pairs of gloves for
five bucks and i would put them on wear
them while i was out so while i touched
things and then i would strip them off i
would actually early on strip off all my
clothes when i got home and put on new
clothes so if this thing was
transmitting on clothing
right you and i had your discovery was
that copper
actually
i covered our um outdoor and indoor to
outdoor door knobs with copper tape
copper tape because copper uh is both an
antiviral and antibacterial right we had
a policy that when and it looks nice
when packages arrived in the cardboard
box says they all do we would leave them
sit for 24 hours because the evidence
was that uh infectious agents couldn't
persist on cardboard for longer than
that so anyway we had an elaborate uh
routine that was based on the fact that
we really knew very little about this
pathogen and one of the things and we're
trying to be careful we were airing in
the in the direction of being careful
because we took this virus very
seriously for reasons we will get back
to you later
um but
i think one of the things that i hope
people will remember about us is that
what what we really did and what got
people's attention early on when we
started live streaming your idea that we
start live streaming from here was it
yep it was your idea um so you're in
good company joe rogan suggested that i
start a podcast you suggested that we
start live streaming yeah well we were i
do remember this we were we were
we were pulling our hair out about the
public health pronouncements already at
that point they were so inconsistent
they seemed to be based on no data or
patently absurd analyses
and i and yeah i think i said to you
something like i really feel like we've
got a lot that we can offer in terms of
how to think through these things even
though even though and we knew this and
therefore we knew that there was
a substantial risk
that we could have been
really wrong on a lot of fronts and you
know we were wrong on a few fronts which
you're about to get to but you know the
basic basically the idea was
we we approach the world scientifically
and evolutionarily and the the second is
a subset um of of the first and not
everyone who has a scientific toolkit
has an evolutionary toolkit
but boy would we love to be able to
help other people use those toolkits to
make decisions for themselves and to
start tracking when it is their own
predictive abilities are getting better
and better so that they can trust
themselves more and more and rely less
and less on external authorities who oh
by the way may have interests that do
not align with yours okay so i want to
go back and refine one thing okay you
said we could have been really wrong
okay not worried about wrong
we aired in the right direction
we aired in the careful direction and we
have done that from the beginning and we
did get some things wrong masks are one
of the things i personally got wrong
okay but i got it wrong in the correct
direction and one of the things that i
think you and i got um
the
got attention that was very positive and
i hope people will remember is that what
we did was we started with a model that
effectively assumed this thing could
transmit any of the ways that these
things transmit and as data came in and
it became clear that this wasn't fomite
transmission that
there was something very important about
the volume of air and the rate at which
it was turning over so that it wasn't
like you contact a particle and you get
sick
it's like there's a period of time
there's a clock ticking and the air
circulation and the volume of the room
and how sick the person that you're
talking to is all of them play a role
and so we built this independence at all
of the all the stages of interface
between virus and person right and we um
you know we uh used what we called uh
you know um
i'm now forgetting the term we applied
to it something like the uh the real
volume of the room or the um the
effective volume effective volume
effective volume so a car is a very tiny
effective volume you open the windows
the volume jumps you go outside the
effective volume goes to infinity and
that's transit where you don't have the
ability to open windows you expect
expect things to be bad and i do think
um
you know we we never
as much as we were airing on the side of
caution
uh neither of us ever
thought it was necessary or a good idea
to um be applying those kinds of
measures outside
outside we understood and you know i
found a i found a paper very early that
had come out of china very early um that
it looked that it tried to track the the
origin of tens of thousands of cases it
was china yeah it was um and and it was
um there was i think only one case out
of the tens of thousands that they could
actually track to an outdoor
transmission and it was a very very sick
person talking at very close range
loudly to his neighbor if memory serves
and um
and effectively he was you know right
the the recipient of the virus in that
case was right in the funnel of you know
an active infection
and you know that
i am i am very grateful that we weren't
we weren't wrong on that because
i i think you're even being too cautious
here right because i think the real
story is
um there was a an opposing force right
there's this thing i think the original
is rahm emanuel who once said uh never
let a good crisis go to waste
right rahm emanuel being a democratic
political gunslinger effectively but i
think what happened the best case here
right the best case is that people took
advantage of a crisis to accomplish
things that they wanted to accomplish
anyway many of which are very much not
in the public's interest but i think you
and i ended up
on the opposite side of a conversation
with an enemy we did not know existed
right which were people who were using
the pandemic for purposes we thought as
you know as a normal person would that
we're all in this together we're all
faced with this virus and figuring out
what to do about it is
a project everybody should be involved
in people should be bringing whatever
tools to bear
that they have at their disposal
and
i think what actually happened is that
as
you know
this thing wanted to create fear
right it wanted to create fear
and it had useful tools at its disposal
that were also potentially in play with
respect to controlling the virus
so it pretended
uh after it was clear in the data
that the outdoor environment was safe it
continued to pretend that it wasn't
because its purpose really wasn't about
the virus its purpose was about um
controlling people and so
you and i became increasingly alarmed
uh as this thing insisted that the
outdoor environment was a place that you
needed to mask in our point was there
actually isn't any evidence of that so
as you and i developed uh a model of how
the virus
functions how it transmits and what
therefore we could relax about the many
measures i mean remember we're talking
about going out with
sacrificial gloves with uh with safety
glasses with
uh a mask right what of this can we
relax because it's actually not relevant
to the transmission of this pathogen at
the same point you and i looked at the
evidence
and it was quite clear that there was
something about the outside environment
that was safe it was unclear initially
whether or not it was safe at night
because one of the reasons it might be
safe was uv light
right and so it became clear actually
that there were two reasons it was safe
outside one was uv light but that even
at night this was not transmitting
outside
and so the point was what we were doing
was refining a model starting with a
very careful overly careful
response and refining it and relaxing it
as
uh
as
as it became clear that you could relax
it and my point about the mass mandates
which ended today
is that we are watching that other thing
which had other purposes finally having
to admit
that it was being overly restrictive
yeah we can talk about how we know that
that's what's going on uh a little later
but
i think that you and i actually forced
the conversation to admit things like
the outdoor environment isn't the same
and to the extent that you're claiming
that you want people masked for
epidemiological reasons
um
you know 99 of the world more than 99 of
the world is in fact safe and you've got
people believing that the world is 100
dangerous why would you do that yeah
well okay a few things one is i went
back and found this paper which was
published in 2021 but i've got the
pre-print from april 2020. you can put
it up if you like zach um i was wrong it
wasn't tens of thousands it was a couple
thousand um cases that they that they
were able to trace um it was china um
as i said from
from january and february um so you know
this is this is extraordinarily early
and what we are told um was was when it
was spreading um so anyway not um not as
as huge a data set as i thought but
still still very large
um and then you know one of the other
things um that you know we were thinking
early on was well you know homeless the
homeless population is going to be very
at risk of this unless you know the
outdoors is protective and sure enough
we've seen no
uh evidence of super spreader events
either or you know or super spreader
or just massive spread either within the
homeless populations or
among protests right and so again people
will remember i think that by um sort of
april and
may of 2020
there had begun to be protests by people
um objecting to
uh to lockdowns and
you know as i remembered it was mostly
about lockdowns and it was mostly people
who were identified by the mainstream
media as being right of center
regardless of what their politics
actually were i don't know um and these
protests were decried widely right like
this this was going to itself cause more
spread of covet and how dare these
people how selfish and then within weeks
of those protests
george floyd died and the protests of
course erupted first
first in
minneapolis and then throughout the u.s
and then throughout the world really and
there were just massive protests you
know here in portland i think it was
over a hundred consecutive nights of
protests that then reliably became riots
and um and at that point
that
over a thousand i think i think i do
have that order of magnitude right over
a thousand health professionals declared
that the real pandemic was racism and
therefore these protests were not just
justified but actually necessary
anyone who still thought
that we were living in a world in which
we were being given advice based on data
and not on ideology could pretty much
conclude at that point that at least a
substantial portion of the health policy
and public health apparatus was
completely out to lunch and you know not
in fact doing what the job description
suggests it's doing um that said
as much as those protests especially at
the point that reliably in portland and
some other places they turned into riots
every night um during the summer and and
fall of 2020 as much as they were
disruptive of an incredible amount of
humanity and goodwill um they were not
super spreader events any more than the
protests uh in the spring of 2020
against the lockdowns and and such were
super spreader events any more than um
there were there was a lot of
transmission among homeless people and
the common theme in all of those is of
course being outside yeah which we
predicted actually at the point that uh
many
were saying you know we were talking
about the blm riots and saying these are
going to be super spreader events our
point was we're not in favor of these
riots as we've described many times
right it's not clear that these are a
hazard in this regard right you and i
went uh to see for ourselves
a few times yep knowing that the outdoor
environment was likely to be safe but
being concerned that this was highly
concentrated and taking place at night
where you didn't have uv light as a
disinfectant um and there are people
yelling right i mean yelling and
singing such as it was um
yeah toneless but
yeah but
anyway like protest
songs
yeah durge
that's being generous but um but you and
i behaved
exactly consistently with what we've
described here right we believed it to
be safe on the basis that it was outside
and we knew what the evidence suggested
about the outside we knew that night was
probably safe but you and i kept moving
so that if we were downwind of somebody
who was sick we would not we would have
a high enough effective volume around us
that we wouldn't contract the virus so i
think we now know that effectively
especially early on in the pandemic it
simply wasn't transmitting outside night
or day
that it would have been safe but airing
in the direction of caution is the
refinement we've done that and we have
relaxed our approach as it has become
clear that certain things are safe and
other things or not
okay can you go to the next photo zac
um
so i'm trying to remember okay that's
the last photo
so here's zach and me
uh there's you sporting the uh chili
pepper bandana now i will say that's my
uh that's my tropical bandana that's
what that is yeah um so
as the pandemic
continued
it became clear so i had initially
thought that cloth masks would be
sufficient because the droplets that
were being transmitted were large enough
that they would be caught it became
clear that we need to keep that up
uh we can
move on okay um
it became clear that if masks were going
to be useful at all that it wasn't going
to be cloth masks so
moving away from cloth masks
was a move in the other direction right
not masking outside was a relaxation
moving to masks that were more likely to
be effective
uh was a move in the other direction but
anyway the point was we were developing
a model
this is zach and me in the elevator as
we were disassembling the the downtown
studio is that the last image
last image okay
um
so now the mandates have come the mask
mandates have come to an end there are
many people in portland
vowing to continue masking my guess is
that won't last but it will be
interesting to see
but nonetheless there are
at least three things about the way this
mandate has come to an end i believe
what happened is the narrative collapsed
and they were forced to lift the mandate
because it was too much too obvious too
many it was too much of a regular joke
that um
you know you need to wear your mask as
you're walking to the table but once you
sit down you know our joke was you know
that you've descended out of the coveted
layer and you're now seated at the table
but the point was this is like tiramisu
right it comes stratified well this goes
back to what we were talking about last
week where they had us in a mindset
where it was like you're making an
effort and both you're putting on your
mask to walk to the table and taking off
your mask when you get to the table our
effort
well but it's it's also well maybe i
have some place to go here but you were
you were on a roll
um so i just want to point out that at
the point that the narrative had come
apart and it became clear that the masks
were not effective
at controlling this virus
um
they decided to lift them but even in
lifting them it was evident that this
was about control and not about
epidemiology and the places that you can
see that so first of all the mandates
themselves right are masks valuable
well the cloth ones don't appear to be
right
so if you were going to have a mandate
you could mandate masks that stood a
chance of actually controlling the virus
to the extent that the mandates were
just that you need to mask then that's
clearly about effort and not
epidemiology well and um it's it's again
the
snitches with stars on their bellies
versus the stages without like do you
have a public indicator of compliance
can we see that you are willing to
comply right um we you know we're long
since past you know early early on
people
including us thought that they were um
effective and i was you know it was it
was disturbing to see masks worn badly
like you know really
you know it's gonna be below your nose
or you're gonna poke a hole in it in
order to play the clarinet like you know
these these pictures that have shown up
like who who is thinking through this at
all right um but over time
uh you know there's so many people who
were just wearing them sloppily such
that it was patently like there there
could be no epidemiological
um story that made sense
um it was just about are you being a
good you know a good little person or
not are you complying it's the
inverse
of uh the yellow star
right
the the nostalgia and david forcing jews
to wear
a star of david to label them
effectively as lesser people right in
this case it was a twist on that where
the idea was the masks indicate that you
were a good person
and
that was obviously
it was obviously nonsense because it
they didn't make an attempt to limit it
to places where the masks actually stood
a chance of being useful or to limit it
to mass that might actually be useful
and then at the point that the narrative
fell apart around these people
and everybody was joking about um
the absurdity of the masked policy
right they didn't do what would
reasonably have been done by anybody who
understood that there was a downside to
the masks right a downside for children
for example developmentally right they
didn't say okay mask mandate
is over effective immediately this is a
mandate that took nothing
uh from the point of view of
architecture you didn't need anything
there was no you know
you didn't need crews to go out and do
anything you just needed to declare it
over and so instead what they did is
they said okay a month out the mask
mandate will be coming to an end as if
that has anything to do with science and
then
oh the narrative crumbled a bit faster
than they were anticipating and so they
moved the date back on us proving that
the initial date which was a month out
was completely arbitrary in in the first
place right so well i mean it's a little
bit
in this case i have even less
justification but you know we used to
joke
that uh mosquitoes obey international
boundaries uh because if you were
traveling through central america you
were going to need your malaria
prophylaxis in nicaragua and in panama
but not in costa rica because costa rica
is malaria free and somehow costa rica
is malaria free but of course so are the
areas of nicaragua and panama that are
near um and maybe i don't know actually
maybe at this point panama is entirely
in
the canal zone the canal zone is so
probably not the border um
actually bogus bogo still has some um
books deltoid archipelago i think still
has some
malaria um anyway i don't remember
exactly what the status is but um
basically the the idea was
you know
there is this disease that is highly uh
transmissible that is affected by these
animals that we know and we've got one
country in the middle of a bunch of
other countries that seems to have
eradicated it so
they're ought to be you know they ought
to benefit from having done this job
such that if you were trying to travel
there you know their costa rica was
trying to build its tourism industry
which it was um and it did so well and
it's you know it's a great place to be
both to do research and to and to just
travel around and explore tropical
ecosystems um you you don't need nor
should you need to be worried about
malaria prophylaxis while you're there
but the idea that you could be standing
on one side of the border versus the
other and need a different thing needed
different prophylaxis is um obviously
imagining that borders are more discreet
than they actually are
and you know this this
feels a little bit like that i i don't
think so my recollection was that as you
crossed from nicaragua into costa rica
you had to show
evidence that you had prophylaxis in
other words you had to display your
bottle to them and if you didn't have it
they made you buy it and take it on the
spot and so from the point of view of
costa rica you know to the extent yeah
was it perfectly absent from costa rica
i'm sure not yeah but um was it very
well managed in costa rica it was and so
to the extent that costa rica can't
manage nicaragua's malaria problem but
it can manage costa ricas you know
where do you get the opportunity
the opportunity to do that but at the
border and so you know was a perfect no
but you know even the arbitrariness of
what
seemed to be a you know
a border that the mosquitoes presumably
did not respect was about the fact that
well you know it's the least arbitrary
place to do it yeah i wasn't actually
thinking about traveling by land between
the places although that is in fact how
we
went between them but you know if you're
back back
back when i used to uh consult the cdc
and thought that they really knew what
they were doing
and would occasionally be talking to the
you know consulting nurse for tropical
um disease at the cdc
um about no actually i'm going to this
region of this country and so you know
really it's going to be a different
species of malaria and your notes don't
say that so i'm going to have to figure
out my own prophylaxis regime um it was
about like if you're flying in to san
jose versus flying into managua costa
rica versus nicaragua
having you know very different actually
mandatory um i think at that point um
things about what you needed to get into
the country when in fact you know they
share a border and the mosquitoes don't
care yeah um is just you know feels a
little arbitrary it's not arbitrary
it just reveals that we have categories
for things and the categories can be
real
but the borders that we put in place
look far less fuzzy than they actually
are
all right um
so there was one more
thing that i wanted to pick up on i
don't remember
what you said that prompted me to think
about um the way that the schools are
responding to um to the mask mandates
and i just want to share the first two
paragraphs of an email i got from the
portland public school system
yesterday and you can show my screen if
you like zac it says dear pps families
this is again portland public
school
on monday portland public schools along
with the majority of oregon school
districts will follow the guidance of
federal state and county officials and
make face masks optional in schools
we know this is a big step for all of us
and that some families will choose to
continue to have their students wear a
mask
we urge everyone to practice
understanding and compassion everyone
masked or not should feel like they
belong regardless of their own personal
decision around covet 19 safety
including the use of masks each family
has its own circumstances and deserves
respect please know that our staff will
not attempt to influence your decision
on masking and will create safe
inclusive classrooms that respect each
individual decision
the rest of the email continues in that
sort of frame
finishing with reminding us that of
course getting vaccinated if you're five
years old or over is the best way to
prevent um
to to keep you and your community safe
and then they have some links to some
um
some materials that you can go over with
your student that clearly designed for
like elementary school students even
though they're sending it to high school
parents of high schoolers um you know
and really pretty insulting to the
intelligence of people
um but in it
they they remind us for instance that uh
in
i think it's all but it might just be
most portland public schools
um people people like us
the the unvaccinated against kovid are
not actually allowed to go onto the
campus for more than 15 minutes at a
time
and
this
you know they want everyone to practice
understanding and compassion personal
decision making respecting each
individual decision
with regard to masks because they are
very certain that they need to keep
people interested in wearing masks and
if they're scared then
the portland public schools
are not going to talk to students about
how fear damages the ability to actually
make conscious smart decisions in the
future they're going to encourage the
fear they're going to encourage the fear
and the language of understanding
compassion and inclusion
and at the same time they're going to
maintain their policy of not letting
people
um
who are adults um the the students they
have not mandated uh
the vaccines for in the portland public
schools um they are not gonna let the
parents of students um who have
rejected this particular plan uh by the
health authorities as a way to uh
protect yourself against disease which
they're now saying the boosters last
three months of that
um they're not that's that's not an
option we don't get to to visit our
children in school
but we need to practice inclusion and
compassion and understanding as we
continue to see people masked unto what
eternity and at one school we've heard
that 90 of the students say that they're
going to keep wearing masks so
what we really have here 90
is a
you have a scientific phenomenon an
epidemiological phenomenon that has an
actual nature you have something that
has hijacked the response to it
and is using things that plausibly
interact right is a vaccine relevant to
controlling a pathogen in principle yes
not if it doesn't block transmission
well right that's why i say in principle
yes so the point is
in principle is not the same as this
vaccine that you happen to have that
says on the bottle it's for covet um is
going to be effective in fact we know
it's not right um
and has
unknown uh risks because it's so brand
new
but the basic point is what you've got
is a public school
left with no
proper
uh
mechanism for navigating what exactly is
a public school supposed to do
when they have been unwittingly drafted
into terrorizing their own students over
a pathogen using masks what are they
supposed to do at the point that the
government without explanation lifts
those mandates in a way that clearly
suggests this has nothing to do with
epidemiology they didn't mandate n95
masks in the first place they mandated
masks they then set an arbitrary date
for removing the mandate they then moved
that date they are announcing to us that
this is about their control over us what
is the public school supposed to do
public school can't very well do what
we've done and call out the governmental
authorities and say they cannot um
you're behaving in an arbitrary
non-scientific
way and we can tell
right
what are they to do they've you know
advocated and in fact enforced the
masked mandate on students despite the
harm developmentally that will come to
those students for not having their
mouths visible to each other for years
of their lives right are they supposed
how are they supposed to deal with i
guess the point is the level to which
the message that this is about your
safety the level to which that
penetrated people's minds varies and now
on lifting it what they have done is
they've given people an option but
really the school's job is a
developmental job yes that is partly
analytical but it is also about learning
how to be in the world
that school has a moral obligation to
discourage the use of masks to the
extent that they are not forced to
require them the developmental value of
having everybody visible so that you
know
here's the the hidden thing we humans
have very specially evolved musculature
in our faces to exchange very subtle
information about you know emotion
and to the extent that that
might have been in conflict with a novel
virus floating around fine but to the
extent that we now acknowledge that this
is not an effective policy for
controlling this virus then we should
actively discourage people from wearing
something that blocks it because it is
in their educational interest in every
regard for them to get all of the
messages because frankly these kids have
catching up to do yeah they do they have
a lot of catching up to do and they have
catching up to do with regard to
all sorts of social interactions and
that includes therefore also one of the
other policies that was widespread which
was about physical distancing
which was at first called social
distancing they tried to sort of rebrand
that but it really was between the masks
and the zoom school and the you know the
distance mandated between students and
the not you know basically no you know
no rough and tumble play not even a
touch at all ever
for you know what what about for the
students who have who come from homes
where they don't get anything right
right then you just you just destroyed a
lot of children and
so the masks mask mandates are lifted
how about how about also letting kids
hang out in small groups again
how about letting them actually you know
laugh reporiously at lunch and
occasionally you know do a spit take
that's never a good idea but like this
is this is part of what growing up is
well
i think the thing is um
i i don't like patting ourselves on the
back here but the right thing to do was
to assume
a
pathogen that could transmit in many
different ways and then upon discovery
about what the actual mode of
transmission was and what was actually
useful to withdraw everything that
wasn't justified by its
utility in controlling the virus and so
the point is from very early on very
early on you could have said kids
be normal outside right indoors wear a
jacket we're going to have the windows
open whatever it was that you needed to
do but the point was
as we
literally said
more than 99 of the world is safe from
this why are we telling people that the
entire world is dangerous that's about
keeping them in fear for reasons that
have nothing to do with controlling a
virus yeah yeah so the exactly the
messaging was simultaneously
simultaneously if you care about other
people you will do everything we say
and
the way that we are going to get you to
do that is you're going to think it's
due to your own compassion but we're
actually going to scare the bejesus out
of you about everything the entire world
is a dangerous place there are crazy
crazy viruses lurking around every
corner and
you just have there's there is no help
for it but um to trust us because you
can tell we got the credentials in the
background and we're the adults here and
boy could we use some real adults yeah
now i do wonder what bejesus is and how
it got into us but um it's not good
i've always wondered but yeah yeah but
it's the kind of question you donate
well most people don't yeah i don't know
if i've ever even said it before i don't
think you have certainly haven't been
around um all right i was trying not to
swear
all right you did a fairly good job
i don't think bejesus is an epithet
[Music]
um that's how you uh
you avoid saying terrible things in
spanish as you say
at least in panama yeah in certain
places um so i did one one last point
yeah is that i think that the
arbitrariness of the end of the mask
mandate here which is um as you point
out not by any means the whole thing
because the
vaccine mandates lurk behind them and uh
and the like but
some places sorry some places are
dropping
you know there's a there's a theater
marquis somewhat near us that for months
now i said you know vaccine required
and that disappeared and it's been
many many months maybe well over a year
now wouldn't it be well every year but
many many months
and it just disappeared and nothing else
was said about it whereas
um other places it's getting worse and
actually
we're not gonna talk about this week but
i understand um that in british columbia
specifically things are getting far
worse
uh specifically for healthcare workers
with regard to vaccine manage exactly as
most of the rest of of canada is at
least
at least reinvestigating uh what it is
they're doing
in the wake not of their
duplicitous ken doll of a prime minister
but of the bravery of the truckers in
taking on many of the stupid rules and
standing strong
well i think that all of the stuff is
going to come apart
you will notice that we have not what is
the name of that snake oil salesman
fauci
um you will notice that we have not seen
much
of anthony fauci lately as he is
enjoying uh basically there was a big
puff of squid ink and he vanished into
the coral reef and um is now moving is
he a moray eel is that what he is no i
like more nails um
but uh anyway as
i think the point is the change of
subject is a great relief to people
around whom their narrative
was collapsing
and i just want to point out one last
thing the arbitrariness
in fact possibly the explanation for why
they set an arbitrary future date and
then moved it as the narrative collapsed
faster than they expected
has to do with the paradox of rachel
maddow and how she dealt with people
will remember there was a moment at
which they were dangling masslessness as
a reward as a perk for vaccination
and the idea was well if you're
vaccinated you don't very well need a
mask because you're both immune and not
going to transmit this thing right
so back when that was still the story
let's give them the benefit of the doubt
let's imagine that they actually
believed it at the time
rachel maddow had a moment where she
said the quiet part out loud on her show
where she was literally trying to
grapple with the cognitive dissonance
that comes from wait a minute now the
good people are the ones without masks
like how is my little mind going to wrap
itself around that update you know
and so the point is this giving you a
month to go through the rachel maddow
moment and get to a place
where it's like okay
got it i now know who the good people
are again i feel comfortable with it i'm
ready to get rid of this mask
may be the reason that they didn't do an
effective immediately but the point is
these are the kind of people who would
not do an effective immediately order
even though the well-being of children
depended on it
well and i mean i think
i'm gonna actually
switch up the order a little bit here um
after
you have put so many
terrible policies in place that have
disrupted the development of young
people
to then say
ah anything the young person says or
feels is the final truth and the final
arbiter of how it is the rest of us are
going to interact with them
is a advocation of responsibility at
every every every level so we're doing
that with regard to
kids and and teenagers and young people
who have been just
emotionally and psychologically and in
many cases otherwise as well
extraordinarily damaged by two years of
this madness and who are now like well i
gotta keep wearing it like it's the only
it's like it's the consistency right
like whatever it is whatever story it is
they tell themselves it doesn't matter
it is the job of the adults to say
actually honey no it's it's it's time
for that to go because you don't need it
you haven't needed it and it's bad for
you same thing with regard to children
who wake up one day you know on tuesday
they decide they're a dinosaur and on
wednesday they they decide their
spider-man and on thursday they decided
that they're the sex that they are not
and
no one tries to get him surgery to turn
into a dinosaur
or
you know decides to wrap them in spider
silk
but
somehow
because
there is
there are very very rare
disorders
uh in which
trans seems to be the best way to
proceed with life
the much the
majority of people who especially as
children who are waking up going
you're actually a boy i'm a girl now or
vice versa um
when parents
and us and health
health professionals
say oh yeah
no we're not gonna of course he's not a
dinosaur of course he's not spider-man
but he is a girl because he said he was
and because he said he was a girl
we are going to stop you know stop
puberty from progressing and then once
we've done that for a while we are going
to start giving cross-sex hormones and
then i mean i guess if it's a boy um
claiming to be a girl the surgical
interventions don't happen as as a
teenager thank god but um the girls who
decide to be boys they're doing what
they're calling top surgery on kids
and you never get that functionality
back nor do you get the functionality
back associated with cross-sex hormones
or with puberty blockers you just don't
why would we ever
take the word
of a child or a teenager as
the reality that everything must follow
this is what childhood is this is not
the moment at which they have everything
figured out everyone who's been a child
or a teenager knows this but especially
in an environment in which we have so
disordered their development in the case
of trans
through um through social media through
screens through um you know
uh hormonal
things in the water of various sorts of
plastics and and such
um and uh and through basically
woke crazy gender ideology in schools
and with regard to covid with regard to
everything we've just talked about
you've disordered the development of
children and now you're going to take
what they claim as the god's honest
truth and we need to change what we do
to deal to accommodate their desires and
fears no it's our job to do the opposite
it's our job to not accommodate their
fears and to help them
undo some of the damage that we have
done to them yes it's effectively a
post-modern mask mandate yeah right
their basic point is look your lived
experience if you think that this does
control the virus then it does keep
wearing it and if you think it doesn't
then you're free to stop and it's like
no no
that is not how this works there's it
either is an effective measure in which
case why are you
eliminating it or it isn't an effective
measure in which case
everybody needs to take those things off
immediately and abdicating
responsibility like this is uh is absurd
but to close this out i just want to
point out
we have traveled the full gamut right
from as far as i know me being the first
person in our environment to mask at all
right i was masking before you know this
was a million miles from a mandate at
the point that i started masking because
it seemed likely to work it was
resentful right you were like you you're
going out to you know you put on a mouth
right but the point is you know what
when there was no evidence about how it
transmitted it made sense to behave that
way as the evidence came in and it
became clear that cloth masks were
ineffective than if there was going to
be a mandate it should have been about
masks that stood a chance of working and
at the point it became clear that this
was not an effective way of controlling
the pandemic we should have gotten rid
of them because everything has a cost
and this one has a particular cost to
children that we should never have known
to bear in this case there are some of
the costs that we can absolutely see and
i remember
oh maybe i don't know six twelve months
ago um at the point that one of the
associations for child psychology i
think it was
came out publicly declaring that there
was absolutely no impact on little
children in like preschool
interacting only with masked kids and
then separately and i won't be able to
call it up now but a couple weeks ago uh
the cdc
quietly and without saying anything um
changed the benchmarks for language
development for young kids and the
number of words that kids are expected
to know at various benchmarks has now
gotten pushed back by six months in
several cases why huh i wonder what
could possibly be going on in the world
for the last two years that would cause
all of the american children to suddenly
get dumber
they're lowering the goal posts
[Laughter]
yep
yeah yeah
so anyway i think i think for the people
uh watching it is worth thinking about
what it takes to
drive people who were as interested in
figuring out what the best practices
were to control this
um
this virus uh as
i hate to say they've driven us crazy
but they certainly may
they have
tested our patients remarkably by
pretending that all of these measures
have utility they don't when the
evidence doesn't support them
and um
you know it's been a profound a profound
transition yeah it sure has
um
god there's so much so much we want to
do and you know let's let's let's talk
orwell a little bit of course shall we
it's the natural thing to talk about
next yeah no i mean i think actually you
will
no i think it is the natural talk about
that i think it is um so i just have a
number of short uh short experts from
this
tiny little book
um
that
i want i want to share
um
let's see
so i says this is this is the road to
wigan pierre by george orwell published
in 1937 and as i said last week it's
basically in two parts the first half
being um
the first half being him documenting
uh the living experiences the lives um
and including with a lot of numbers a
lot of statistics about how much people
are making and how much they're spending
on rent and and various food items and
such um the lives of the mostly coal
miners and and which includes also
unemployed coal miners in um i think
it's lancashire and
yorkshire maybe i admit that i did not
remind myself of uh english geography
before
coming on today um and then the second
half is uh his social analysis uh in
which he also shares some biographical
details of his own life um he describes
himself basically as having had a
bourgeois upbringing
but uh by the numbers he makes a um you
know sort of
lower middle class
uh income so he's sort of he's
he doesn't exactly love this languaging
but he sort of is is
is he's bringing in money at the sort of
upper proletariat level um but his but
he pronounces all of his ages is in in
in the language here and um so is
culturally very much of the bourgeoisie
uh even though he's making an order of
magnitude less than what most people
might be considered um
in in the bourgeoisie in england at the
time
um and so the the second part of the
book from which these quotes are from is
him sort of working through why he
is in favor of socialism although i
don't think he ever actually defines
what he means by that in here which is
which is interesting despite having um
basically no appreciation for almost any
socialist he has ever met
um and i will end um i i'd love us to
talk just a little bit about each of
these as i go but the last couple um are
his characterizations of socialists
which is i just i don't know my history
well enough to know what the hell he's
talking about but but you'll see what i
mean okay
here we go this is from chapter nine
he's talking about himself as a young
man
i had reduced everything to the simple
theory that the oppressed are always
right and the oppressors are always
wrong a mistaken theory but the natural
result of being one of the oppressors
yourself
i felt that i had got to escape not
really from imperialism but from every
form of man's dominion over man i wanted
to submerge myself to get right down
among the oppressed to be one of them
and on their side against their tyrants
and chiefly because i had had to think
everything out in solitude i had carried
my hatred of oppression to extraordinary
lengths at that time failure seemed to
me to be the only virtue every suspicion
of self-advancement even to succeed in
life to the extent of making a few
hundreds a year
seemed to me spiritually ugly a species
of bullying
so this reminds me so much of
the kinds of thinking that we were
seeing in the in the blm protests in the
summer of 2020
and in the diversity equity and
inclusion
ideology generally that of course is
what took over evergreen and is you know
is one thing that you can point to is
the reason that we are no longer there
um that there is a
there is a knee-jerk
duality that people believe in that
actually couldn't possibly be
representative of what is true of life
well this is interesting that that quote
you read is timeless or at least yeah
yeah yeah he's equally at home in the
present as it was when he wrote it
uh i do want
this strikes me as
needing one extra level of complexity to
what or wilson yeah yeah so i i've
been thinking a lot about socialism and
communism and
revolts like the one we are seeing and
why you know no
yeah
that basically to some of us
the idea of meritocracy is obviously
right right i don't believe we have one
right i don't believe you can have a
perfect one but is it the right thing to
do yes for many many reasons that are
relatively easy to point to
on the other hand
if you have a situation in which you
define merit as the thing that uh
is to be rewarded
there comes a point at which
many people discover that they are on
the losing end of that battle right that
their tools are not sharp enough to do
the job
now
it should be the case that we
democratize the tools right so that
everybody so that effectively you have
the tools should you be willing to put
in the effort to achieve something
meritorious enough to
you know to live well in yeah in so far
as is possible understanding that there
will be no perfect world and you cannot
fully democratize
uh either access or origin right
allowing for the noise that will
certainly uh be a countervailing force
to merit merit is a good thing to
prioritize and to try to reward but the
point is what if you had a system that
just sucked
right and that system was
prone to miseducate people to waste
their developmental time so that at the
point that they arrive at adulthood they
discover they don't have any useful
tools right
that isn't the fault of the people who
were miseducated but it does suggest a
reason that they would find themselves
in a coalition fighting merit right yeah
the whole idea of fighting merit seems
like a paradox until you realize well
especially in a system that sucks and
doesn't equip most people for a
meritocracy
why wouldn't you naturally find again
and again in history this uh discovery
that maybe meritocracy isn't real maybe
we should you know fight the very
concept of merit maybe it's maybe it's
an illusion to begin with right you
should rediscover that
repeatedly and i have a sense that
that's
that's why we are here again that's why
orwell seems to have written something
that would be at home in you know 2018
right
and anyway we should keep it in mind yes
oh that's that's excellent
yeah
okay um
so he there's a this is from a longer
section i'm mostly going to summarize it
he's talking about um the bourgeois um
the bourgeoisie making many
pronouncements because they're
fashionable but with which they
themselves don't agree and if and they
are it's sort of a gentleman's agreement
the people will declare that they think
that such and such is ridiculous but if
uh someone usually from the lower
classes is to come and say exactly the
same thing they'll take umbrage and be
like no you can't say you're not allowed
to say that it's only those of us on the
inside um and this is you know what he's
talking about is the is the bourgeois
socialists right like he's not he's he's
mostly talking about the people who are
claiming to be socialists but who are
actually you know of the middle class
and who are very interested in class
distinctions and in frankly in
maintaining them um despite the ideology
that they
propose to
follow
um
so he says specifically quote the
left-wing opinions of the average
intellectual are largely spurious
um and i think this is consistent with
what we have observed when we say things
like the pseudo left and you know we
still we still understand ourselves to
be on the left because
because
while we have a different understanding
of
what
many conservatives actually believe
our fundamental understanding of of our
worldview is not changing even as other
people who claim to believe the same
things we do are changing yeah it's not
about a flag or a jersey yeah or or a
social group right right it's not it's
not about social group it's about actual
actual values
and then he says and this may sound
well i'll just read the sentence and see
what you think
it is only when you meet someone of a
different culture from yourself
that you begin to realize what your own
beliefs really are
yeah this reminds me uh of what you and
i
used to talk about when we would come
home from
work in the field
we always uh talked about the culture
shock of returning home if you you know
it's not something you get if you've
been gone for two weeks it's something
you get if you've been gone for months
or longer yeah and
it is it's a little uh it's a weird
connection to make but it's a little bit
like the
um the jarring nature of a
hallucinogenic trip
right
because it allows you to see your own
culture in a way that it is impossible
to and the thing that was most jarring
to me when we did it was you come home
and the advertising the billboards and
the yeah and the commercials and it's
just like
you you don't realize that you've gotten
used to this just insidious voice that
is manipulating you in the most
egregious ways well in this way actually
our
both of our
not terrific facility with additional
languages uh makes it easier to exist in
a different space and not feel
completely bombarded like you know
we
our
we were both able to get along okay in
various other languages um but neither
of us is close to fluent and so you know
there's plenty of advertising a lot in
american cities plenty but it's not
targeted too
we're both not the target and because
the language isn't one in which we have
complete fluency um it's easier to tune
out
well it's also you know as you'll
remember i used to
i've gone looking for these photos i
don't know where they are but um
the
supermarket right uh in latin american
countries if you look at like the hair
color aisle or really the baby food
aisle or anything right a bunch of
blonde blue eyed it's you know there's
ethnicity to the people on the boxes but
it definitely leans super light skinned
and it has very uh european overtones
and it just doesn't look like the
population in the supermarket um and the
point is there's a message there about
class and refinement and origin and and
all of this and it is
um
well it explains a great deal about why
the world works the way it does right
and uh but you could see it very clearly
if you're not uh
if you're not latino and you're in a
latin american supermarket it's plain as
day that there's something weird going
on in the shampoo aisle right um it's
not plain as day to you at home
right and uh so anyway it's it's
yes the adventures away are very useful
for seeing yourself absolutely and this
is part of you know this is part of
a big part of why we both advocate so
strongly for travel and not you know not
disney fight travel yeah at all i mean
that that might be for some people that
is fun
um but
travel in which you're actually outside
of your own culture and in which um
you're not saying you have to rough it
but in which you are actually
experiencing the world as some other
people do and you are other and you you
know you will never be other the way
that some people live as other
inextricably and unchangeably for
throughout their entire lives because at
any moment if you've gone someplace
presumably you can pick up and go home
so it's different
um but existing as the odd thing the um
the one that can't blend in that can
never be invisible and that is
as also being a trying to be a
participant observer to be a kind of
anthropologist
um and um and
learn you know make some friends and
learn something about the culture and
the food and the music and the other
festivals and everything and come to see
how many different glorious ways there
are of being human on this planet and
then you know then to come back
and find that it's really hard to
communicate a lot of that to the people
who weren't with you you know to your
friends back home uh to you know to
describe carnival for instance or just
the experience of
um
you know
getting tacos at any type of day or
night for 30 cents a piece and they're
the most delicious thing you've ever had
and that's how people eat and like you
know i can say that but it's just it's
it's
different to be walking in this in the
central square and to have that be your
life day after day week after week month
after month yeah i would say there's a
temptation
uh to travel in ways that people solve
problems for you and it is a little bit
hard to it is very true but a little bit
hard to defend
that part of what the most important
aspect of the whole thing is
is
what you
what you will happen onto as you solve
utterly mundane problems right like i
need to go buy a comb how do i you know
exactly and there we are we're back at
serendipity which is a theme from last
week and a theme
that i bring up all the time and it was
actually one of the um one of the
tensions that i felt um and i i may have
even talked about this on air before but
um
you know i loved doing the study abroad
that i did and you know we of course did
the 11 week study abroad as our as our
final one but i had done several before
that and it really was one of the things
that i felt that i could i could bring
to students um very uniquely to you know
some students who'd never been more than
50 miles away from where they've been
born help them get a passport help them
get a grant and take them to the amazon
it's like you know look at the world
right it's amazing
um
but
i was i was a little bit um
of two minds about it because while i
left a lot of open space and a lot of
room for serendipity and a lot of room
for people to make mistakes
including mistakes that were cultural
and that maybe put them at some some
risk
the fact is that i i organized
everything you know there were there was
one moment i remember when i'm like okay
it's 16 months away and i'm planning
lunch because you know because we're
gonna be on a boat here and then here
and like we have to know exactly where
we're gonna stop because we're gonna
have 30 people and you know we need to
we need to have planned lunch that's a
level of planning that i could do and i
did and you know it was
you know it was rewarding in its way
but the students knowing that they were
in the capable hands of someone who had
done all the planning meant that they
were not going to have the same kind of
learning experience um that they would
if they had just um even just had to
pack for themselves without a you know
without a carefully constructed packing
list right and likewise um
for many of them even at the point that
they're on their own in some city
uh they will often go out in a large
group which
uh diffuses the responsibility and
reduces the value of the problem-solving
that one does and it's like people who
are familiar with college campuses what
freshmen do for the first couple weeks
on campus you know they combine into a
group and it's like oh that's that's
that's freshmen because it's 14 of them
right
um but it was always
always interesting to see which students
actively chose not to do that right and
you know the student that you know
you're you're all the way across panama
city and you run into them and they're
alone right that's always an interesting
student right that's somebody who
quickly learns about the world mm-hmm
um yeah
all right let's do a couple more
um
let's see this is
end of chapter 10.
this then is the net result of most
meetings between proletarian and
bourgeois they lay bear a real
antagonism which is intensified by the
proletarian can't itself the product of
forced contacts between class and class
the only sensible procedure is to go
slow and not force the pace
if you secretly think of yourself as a
gentleman and as such the superior of
the green grocer's errand boy it is far
better to say so than to tell lies about
it ultimately you have got to drop your
snobbishness but it is fatal to pretend
to drop it before you are really ready
to do so
meanwhile one can observe on every side
that dreary phenomenon the middle class
person who is an ardent socialist at 25
and a sniffish conservative at 35 in a
way his recoil is natural enough at any
rate one can see how his thoughts run
perhaps a classless society doesn't mean
a beatific state of affairs in which we
shall all go on behaving exactly as
before except that there will be no
class hatred and no snobbishness perhaps
actually it means a bleak world in which
all our ideals our codes our tastes our
ideology in fact will have no meaning
perhaps this class breaking business
isn't so simple as it looked on the
contrary it is a wild ride into the
darkness and it may be that at the end
of it the smile will be on the face of
the tiger with loving those slightly
patronizing smiles we set out to greet
our proletarian brothers and behold our
proletarian brothers in so far as we
understand them are not asking for our
greetings they are asking us to commit
suicide
when the bourgeois sees it in that form
he takes to flight and if his flight is
rapid enough it may carry him to fascism
yeah
it is
extraordinary it's tragic that he didn't
live longer and yeah that we don't have
him uh
presently yeah uh
there's so much in there one is this
sort of sense that the um the
downtrodden are of fundamentally
better stuff which they in fact may be
as long as they're downtrodden but the
point is what turns
the elites terrible and it's not
universal but what turns the elite
terrible is the elite status and so that
whoever acquires it ends up either you
know has to deliberately fight the
transition into that thing yeah right or
it happens to them right you can't you
know if the first will be last and the
last will be first then the point is
well you're going to reinvent the
problem with new actors right yes
yes it's still people it's still still
people in the game theory is still the
game theory yeah yeah you ain't done
nothing to change that yeah
um
okay one uh two more
let me see i gotta figure out what i'm
starting with the kind of person here we
go the kind of person who most readily
accepts socialism is also the kind of
person who views mechanical progress as
such with enthusiasm
and this is so much the case that
socialists are often unable to grasp
that the opposite opinion exists
as a rule the most persuasive argument
they can think of is to tell you that
the present mechanization of the world
is as nothing to what we shall see when
socialism is established where there is
one airplane now in those days there
will be fifty all the work that is now
done by hand will then be done by
machinery everything that is now made of
leather wood or stone will be made of
rubber glass or steel it's pretty
plastic
there will be no disorder no loose ends
no wildernesses no wild animals no weeds
no disease no poverty no pain and so on
and so forth
the socialist world is to be above all
things an ordered world an efficient
world
oh my god
yeah that's uh
uh i mean it's it's true that it's true
and and you know it really goes there is
it there is a dislike
sorry but like
i think the stereotype is that um and
and this is true of some conservatives
is that they want to control nature and
that they you know and they and i
remember seeing some stuff early in sars
in in kovid right with some prominent
conservatives saying like just control
it just kill the virus just like you
know get in a bottle and get rid of it
and it's like well that's a naive
understanding but you know he he lays
out a bunch of the history that at that
point wasn't history that he was living
through in which he really demonstrates
that that's actually the you know the
love of mechanization and of having
machines do all the work that is
currently done by by laborers is part of
the utopian vision of the socialists at
that point anyway
yes and you know it's
it's oddly inconsistent right because i
think probably this is the influence of
you know
dilite socialists yeah that the point is
the machinists are going to be aware of
the trade-offs inherent in things and
they may of course envision machines
doing things but they will not you know
they will envision tolerances and
noise in the system and failure and all
of that they won't have this
you know this shiny view of everything
being you know a life of leisure because
the machines are doing all the work you
know uh but anyway
it's curious yeah
um
okay
one more with
i'm just gonna read this one
this is from chapter
11 that last one is from chapter 12.
this is from chapter 11.
the first thing that must strike any
outside observer is that socialism in
its developed form is a theory confined
entirely to the middle class
the typical socialist is not as
tremulous old ladies imagine a ferocious
looking working man with greasy overalls
in a raucous voice he is either a
youthful snob bolshevik who in five
years time will quite probably have made
a wealthy marriage and been converted to
roman catholicism or still more
typically a prim little man with a
white-collar job usually a secret tea
totaler and often with vegetarian
leanings with a history of
non-conformity behind him and above all
with a social position which he has no
intention of forfeiting
this last type is surprisingly common in
socialist parties of every shade it has
perhaps been taken over on block from
the old liberal party
in addition to this there is the
horrible the really disquieting
prevalence of cranks wherever socialists
are gathered together
one sometimes gets the impression that
the mere word socialism and communism
draw towards them with magnetic force
every fruit juice drinker nudist sandal
wearer sex maniac quaker nature kira
quack pacifist and feminist in england
all right
i'm feeling good because i think i
nailed two of these
on this podcast
i don't know what his problem with
vegetarians and feminists and nature
like this is such a crazy list we could
spend so long on this list
no it may be it may be that um basically
you get
that there's something pathological
about being drawn
at a certain level into causes right yes
causes are important but the point is
he's identifying people who
synonymize themselves but sandalware is
brett and he's uh he also talks about
beard havers that's weird
that's not his language i don't remember
what he calls it but like bearded
bearded teetotallers or something
um
but hold on i want to recover two things
one of them
he says exactly the thing that i said
just a moment before you read that where
he basically says you'd think that these
socialists are
you know these hard-working hard-headed
no people they're not it's not them he
specifically calls out the machinist
um
and what was the other thing
damn i've lost it was it about his um
his hatred of quakers and people who
think nature can cure things well no i
think it was refrigerated drinkers um
in his listing of all of these things
right he is talking about people who do
not sound
well
endowed for meritocracy we're talking
about people who've narrowed their scope
to
[Music]
you know
whatever it is that sandal wears to
narrow their scope too i mean he's
talking about if he's talking about hip
some of that is like descriptive of
hippies before hippies exist but um
right but but the point is if if what
i'm saying is true and that in effect
there is this ever-present pull to rebel
against merit right to declare merit of
fiction where would you tend to find it
right you would find it amongst people
who have overly synonymized themselves
with something that isn't productive
right
vegetarianism may be good or it may be
bad but it's not productive right it's
not like
so i don't know what nature he's got
that in quotes capitalized exactly
refers to there but um there's certainly
a lot in the phrase that i can i can i
can put a lot of good sense to yeah
right uh and you know feminism has had a
lot of missteps but that was you know
we're in first wave feminism era at that
point and
uh the idea of you know being allowed to
work outside the home and keep your name
when you get married um i you know i i
don't i just i'm i'm so curious because
he goes off on with lists like that a
few times at the end of the book that's
just one of them um and you know i was
listening i was walking in this park
with all these people unmasked around me
and i would just start laughing out loud
like oh he's off on another tie right
about people with beards and wearing
sandals well let's try this out okay um
you know this thing that i always say
uh
i am a liberal who wants to live in a
world so good that i get to be a
conservative yeah right i think most
people don't understand what i'm getting
at but but the point is
i actually do want to see something done
and at the point that it's done
continuing to try to do it doesn't make
any sense it's not action for action's
sake right so
map that onto feminism sure right i'm a
feminist that wants to live in a world
so egalitarian that i don't have to be a
feminist
right that seems to make sense to me
right it doesn't mean we're there on the
other hand where we are is something
that should always be a question because
whether or not
i i agree with you i just not everything
on that list works i'm a sandalware who
wants to live in a world so cold that i
can't we're saying just like
i just can't quite make it right it
doesn't it doesn't map on to everything
and again the you know nature cure may
have been some particular thing but i
mean i do think your larger point about
belonging about signifiers of tribalism
um really like people who both you know
want to adopt the latest thing and you
know we we heard about this and we saw
this directly both at evergreen and we
see in the black lives matter movement
and we see it frankly with cove but
people who are just like oh and you know
we see it in social media tags we're
like oh it went from
it went from syringes to ukrainian flags
right in people's names on social media
you know i'm gonna i'm gonna signal that
i'm on the next big thing and like did
you even know anything about vaccines
the ukraine or any of this before uh you
were told that this is what you were
supposed to think about now oh but you
like to feel like you're inside and you
know so so doesn't everyone at some
level but if you if that is one of your
driving things then maybe you end up
being one of these bearded
sandal-wearing vegetarian feminists that
or well so rails against yep i mean i
still want a fruit choose drinker i
still want to abstract it out okay
because
you know if you decided
um that uh you know
merit was synonymous with um
uh
deadlifting right that we're gonna be
able to figure out how meritorious and
we're gonna reward you based on how
meritorious you are based on how how
much you can deadlift okay right
that doesn't sound like a world that i'm
very much in favor of merit
right that sounds like a world that's
been stacked the cards have been stacked
against me right and so
one can imagine that for any description
of merit
some large number of people will be able
to look at it and say
okay that's a world in which i lose
i'm not for that world
right and
that the question is
does orwell's seemingly arbitrary list
of things that we can't even quite
figure out what he's talking about is
the idea that people who are likely to
end up on that list very closely
synonymized with some quirk
are those also people who are likely not
to be on board with the idea of merit
because they it feels like a conspiracy
against them
right yeah
something like that
no i think i think i think that's right
i think you're onto something
um you said on to something not on
something i i you may be but i had not
yet formulated a hypothesis on that
front excellent yeah
um it's
it's already 2 15 our time um but you
have been saying for a couple weeks now
that you want to talk a little bit about
uh why the why the origin of sorry's
kovi 2 likely through some serial
passaging research
affects you know makes a difference it's
not just a historical question
but
potentially makes a difference in terms
of the epidemiology
well and specifically the individual
level illness
right it makes a
big difference excuse me uh that
effectively is why we are still
fighting over
whether it had a laboratory origin and
it became very common especially amongst
sophisticates who had not been early on
the lab leak issue
to declare what does it matter
uh we're stuck with this virus now let's
just deal with it and the answer is
actually a few things matter more
the obvious reason is that to the extent
that this is the product of a laboratory
accident
knowing how that could possibly have
happened so that we can prevent it is
essential but that's obvious
what i think is not obvious
is how much
harm was likely done by that route
and this is why we have to get this
right so
couple points
one
i believe and i hope that we are
ultimately able to get past all of the
people who want to prevent
an honest exploration
i believe that what we had was a brief
period of time after sars kovi ii
emerged in the world
in which we really could have driven it
to extinction just as sars cov1
effectively is extinct right
it seems to have driven itself to
extinction right it did not have it
didn't have the
the goods to keep going and the question
is could we have delivered sars kovi to
sufficient disadvantage in transmitting
if we had gotten to it early and had
taken the politics out of it could we
have driven it to extinction and i
believe what we now know suggests that
we probably could have right or that
failing that we could have driven it to
a state
uh of extreme rarity where it's
effectively extinct like rabies in the
first world
um so
if that is true if what happened was
however this thing emerged into the
world let's assume the best let's assume
uh it was research that it was
well-intentioned research rather than
dual-purpose weapons research let's
assume they were trying to figure out
they were really afraid of a
pathogen getting into the world
of a particular nature they wanted to
study it so that they would be ahead of
the game when it happened and they
goofed and it escaped right that's still
a terrible story and i believe
uh likely the pathogen never would have
made the jump no pathogen like the one
that they were looking at would have
made the jump and become a pandemic
so the point is everything that happens
negative as a result of that jump having
been made with human assistance
goes on the bill of the people who made
the error
uh in judgment but
before you go but um
which is part of why i think it's so
important for the messaging coming from
those people and the people who side
there on
uh to convince the world that it has a
zoonotic origin basically it it it
furthers you know it
they could not be responsible for
something with zoonotic origin but it
also helps keep the population in fear
oh my god at any moment in in a in a
world that is populated as we are where
we're constantly going into wilderness
areas and running into animals ooh scary
animals then um at any moment we could
have another one of these things we'd
better keep things clean we'd better
trust the authorities we'd better you
know get the public health policy you
know and and you know what the who is
working on right now is ridiculously
scary and it um you know they are
actually playing on people's fear that
they have that this entire situation has
created in order to move forward a you
know authoritarian mandate that
potentially has the capacity to
undermine um sovereign governments
this goes squarely back to what we
discussed last week
with the fact that the um
the mechanism of procuring grants has
turned all sorts of people that we need
to do objective science into salesmen
they don't even necessarily understand
that that's what they've become right it
is so reflexive and so in effect there
is a
section of each of the grants that goes
towards such research that says
something akin to
you know as the human population expands
we are coming into more and more contact
with wildlife and wildlife is being
pressured to blah blah blah that is
going to result in pathogens that
normally circulate amongst wild animals
making a zoonotic jump to people at
which point boom and then you come up
with some really crazy level of fear
about what type of pathogen could
suddenly emerge and not be controllable
and therefore why it is absolutely
essential that every
god-fearing mask-wearing grant-giving
agency has to deliver a huge amount of
money to these people who are the only
ones to study the pathogen before it
leaps out of a cave and gets us all yeah
because what will probably be obvious
but might not be known to people is that
every grant application
um that i have ever seen and i saw a ton
of them back when i spent a year working
with the grand agency university of
california at santa cruz many years ago
but have since seen and heard about many
many others is that um
yes they are supposed to be assessed on
their scientific merits but there is a
section of every single one and as i
remember it actually many grant
applications begin and end with versions
of that same section and that section is
basically explain why you deserve money
which is not the same as explain why
this is good science well and so there
you know their needs hopefully there is
good science in the stuff that is being
funded but the decision to fund
is based in part and it's got to be
largely given that it's bracketing
almost every grant application you know
what what is it about your work that
demands funding now which means
increasing the sense of urgency uh is
more likely to get you funding right and
so it effectively is
smoke and mirrors boilerplate and the
basic point is
either the people reviewing the grant
are in on why this isn't exactly true
but they're not going to call it out
because they're in the same business or
they can't see through it because they
don't have the expertise that would tell
them why that's a [ __ ] story right
you know human beings expanding and
coming into more and more contact with
wildlife
[ __ ] right now it happens there are
more people and it happens we are
backing the wild farther and farther
away but people coming into contact with
wildlife is the entire history of people
right which means most of the things
that can make an easy jump have done it
a higher proportion of the human
population was always in more contact
with wildness than the proportion of the
human population that is in contact with
wildness is now right and
viewers may be interested to go back to
my unheard essay where i as a former bat
biologist this is a different one than
you referenced earlier yeah i as a
former bat biologist go through the
question at the point that covid emerges
into the world i then have to wonder if
being in contact with bats is enough to
unleash a pandemic like this could i
have accidentally done it when i was in
contact with bats and the answer is very
likely not
that this is actually a difficult
evolutionary jump and that there you
know you have lots of people you have
thousands of people studying bats at any
one time
we're not constantly causing pandemics
why is that and the answer is because
the thing that they say at the beginning
of those grant applications about the
danger of this happening on any given
tuesday right that's [ __ ] designed
to get the system to spit out money
that's right and so okay
in light of all that you've got the
[ __ ] designed to get the system to
spit out money it spits out money to
fund a reckless kind of research that is
very likely to do exactly the thing that
nature is not well poised to do right
it's very likely to unleash a pathogen
into the world
yeah isn't this one
okay um so
you might just suck
let dad keep talking but um just put on
the screen for a moment and i'll post in
the show notes too go for it so in
effect you've got
a difficult evolutionary leap
um
that a pathogen would have to make in
order to become a human pandemic then
you have
humans who are clever but not that
clever proposing to do exactly the thing
that will make it a small evolutionary
leap right they're proposing to use
trampolines and catapults to get the
thing across the gap to become
capable of in of creating a pandemic on
the basis of the absurd argument that in
order to know what to do about a
pandemic we're going to have to create
something that's capable of making one
which of course runs the risk that the
thing is going to leap into the
uh the world at any moment because lab
accidents are not uncommon at all
um and so okay so then the question is
well
what about the people frankly like sam
harris who said uh well you know i i
wasn't i sam wasn't animated about the
question of lab leaks because at some
level it's an academic question we've
got this virus what's the best way to
deal with it
and the answer is no this makes all the
difference in the world because what in
effect is going on if you think back to
the natural origins paper the christian
anderson lead paper so christian
andersen interacted with fouchy
behind closed doors in his email
uh anderson
um
argued that in fact the viruses they
were coming to know it was inconsistent
with evolutionary theory it could not
have come about naturally and
effectively a plan emerges to obscure
that and suddenly there's a reversal of
course and anderson and uh his academic
cronies cook up a paper that says this
virus has to have come from nature it
couldn't have come from the lab and
here's how you know and their argument
is nonsense their argument is we would
not have known that the structure we see
would be any good at infecting people
therefore we wouldn't have planned it
this way if people were going to make a
virus they wouldn't have made this one
which is true
what they didn't say
was that there's another mechanism that
we're not that good at doing things like
describing a virus that's going to
infect people but what we're really good
at doing is borrowing tools from nature
right we borrow enzymes to do genetic
engineering we borrow antibiotics to
fight off bacteria we borrow evolution
to solve problems we are not smart
enough to solve yet and so serial
passaging was the thing that they were
avoiding describing in that manuscript
right so they do not say what we're
going to do or what likely has accounted
for the existence of this virus is that
the virus a ancestor virus was passed
from one individual to another
evolving along the way to answer the
question how would you make a pathogen
for humans if you don't know enough to
specify its molecular nature
so
what that in effect
does is it creates a virus with the
characteristics that the people who ran
the experiments wanted it to have
um
but it also has other characteristics so
at the same time they were selecting
for the capacity to infect human tissues
they were also selecting for what i
would call explorer modes they were
selecting for a virus that was
experimenting
furthermore if you think about the
question of what virus we ended up with
you know you and i heather have been
very careful
not to fall into the trap of saying this
isn't a dangerous virus right from the
beginning we talked about the fact that
actually this is quite a scary virus and
that the level of uh danger is not
captured in the comparatively low case
fatality rate right there seems to be
lots of harm done
uh around the body that uh isn't
captured there which
you know my telomere work suggests is
going to accelerate aging and shorten
lives
so
so then the point is
is anything about what makes this virus
actually dangerous
uh the result of the mechanism used to
generate it
and
the point of the point i want to make is
let's say that you used ferrets which
have an ace2 receptor similar to humans
in order to get evolution to solve the
question of how you take a virus poorly
adapted to infect humans
the ancestor uh virus to cyrus cov2 and
get it to be really good at infecting
humans so
ferrets are likely serial passage
organism
so called humanized mice mice that have
been altered so they are molecularly
more similar to humans are a likely
place for serial passaging and human
airway tissue
which can be purchased and basically uh
uses evolution to solve the question of
how to get from cell to cell
um
in human airways so all of these things
are places where evolution could have
been used to solve this puzzle yep but
what will happen let's take the ferret
example
in nature
a virus that infects a
ferret
needs to leave the ferret capable of
doing ferret stuff in order for the
ferret to spread the virus to others
otherwise the you know remember the are
not term how uh
you know how many cases can an
individual case spur if if a ferret is
only capable of infecting its you know
family members in the borough and it's
not going to encounter other ferrets in
the population and neither are they
right then r naught is going to be less
than one and the thing will go extinct
so that's not a successful plan so the
point is
there's certain pathogens that don't
work this way malaria for example knocks
you flat on your ass why because you're
not spreading it mosquitoes are so you
being so the analysis is different with
a vectored pathogen right because if
you're lying down and you can't swat a
mosquito then the mosquito is in a good
position to pick it up and move it and
the analysis will be different uh with
the waterborne um waterborne and you
know as everyone you know became
familiar with and probably mostly forgot
the difference it's going to be
different for aerosolized versus
airborne
for you know foam light transmission you
know mode of transmission vector versus
not all of these are going to have
different predictions
um that come along with them about
whether or not you expect virulence to
evolved um
to be a pathogen to become more violent
over time in a population or less
population density of course as well
so
um if you're going to use
laboratory serial passaging yep what you
are doing is you are actually
creating a route that the pathogen
couldn't go through in nature
and i would just point
to several features of this virus
that are probably far worse by
virtue of the fact
that serial passaging is the likely
explanation for where they came from
critically
if a pathogen in order to get from one
individual to the next let's say a
respiratory pathogen requires you to be
mobile so you can't be terribly sick
right then trade-offs being what they
are
it has an incentive not to do any damage
to tissue that isn't directly involved
in transmission right to the extent that
you have tissues that aren't capable of
spreading the virus
because they're not exposed to the
outside world and everybody who
contracts the virus is getting it uh
from a respiratory source and the point
is well that reduces your mobility
without increasing transmissibility so
nature wouldn't do that on the other
hand
if you've got ferrets caged together
where they don't have to find each other
and they don't have to you know look
healthy right imagine you know creatures
in nature are liable to have a revulsion
for individuals of their species who
look sickly right it's natural that you
would evolve that
because of course not every sickly
individual has something transmissible
but a lot of them do and so sickly
individuals are something to be avoided
but if you're caged with a sickly
individual your preference to avoid them
doesn't matter because you can't avoid
them so lots of things about this maybe
even anosmia
right to the extent that a ferret in
order not to starve to death has to
depend on its extraordinary sense of
smell
right a virus that disrupts that
extraordinary sense of smell is
immediately going to cause a uh a
foraging problem for a ferret yeah but
not in a not in a cage where the ferret
eats ferret kibble right
so you could get things like an osmia
which wouldn't naturally be likely to
happen because the ferret needs to be
ecologically capable yeah so interesting
i mean that so
there might be two different possible
approaches like an osmia might be
adaptive in this situation and not in a
you know a normal ferret situation or um
and this seems far more likely the one
that you've proposed uh enosmia might be
acceptable and not come with the normal
cost in this situation that it would in
a wild ferret population right exactly
in this case anosmia is annoying it's
not obvious that it has long-term
implications but the point is it does
seem conspicuous right much like a virus
that can only be transmitted indoors
well that also seems like an arbitrary
uh laboratory phenomenon potentially
that that one strikes me more like it's
about effective volume and you know i
think most
most viruses that are sort of airborne
aerosolized are going to at least
have a strong
be much more likely to transmit indoors
although uh the degree to which that is
true for this one does seem extreme no i
i agree that they will it'll be more
likely for any respiratory virus that is
not
transmitted but the degree to which it
is true in this virus is conspicuous for
something that supposedly uh
came from the wild yeah and of course
the point is trade-offs are under all of
this so if you can borrow from outdoor
transmission without a cost because
you're
in caged animals then you will tend to
borrow in that and you will get
something on some other characteristic
that you know we don't know the two are
connected yep um but anyway my and you
know this one it may be that the
laboratory origin actually worked for us
because it left the outside environment
a place that one could actually be safe
if not for bad cdc advice and things
like that
well but
but for the laboratory origin we
wouldn't have it at all so you know
you don't want to go down that road too
far you can't you can i started by
saying
uh if laboratory origin then effectively
you've got everything everything
downstream it belongs on their bill even
worse to the extent that people then
took a crisis that we could potentially
have ended if we had behaved in a
coordinated and smart fashion and
decided to utilize it for other purposes
right people made bank
well not even made bank the point is
huma
let's say that this was
a mild disease let's say that this was
somewhere between cold and flu okay
the cost to humanity in fact even the
number of deaths is incalculable if
you're stuck with it forever
right and so the point is the costs of
even if that was it even if that was it
yeah you know okay we had flu and now we
got another one right that is a disaster
and for anyone to have used this for
their own purposes
and at the same time run out the clock
that that was running on us actually
controlling the thing is uh
you know it's it's diabolical
yeah and i um
go on okay so let me just close this out
so you've got various characteristics
that may
you know these are hypotheses may be
connected to serial passaging in a
laboratory environment that is not like
nature one of them is the exploratory
nature of this uh
uh pathogen right the tropism for
different tissues
is uh high and it may even be that its
ability to jump species is high because
it's been run through you know some
training courses
um tropism you're using in a way that is
that i'm not familiar with
it's a different definition than in
botany although maybe it's an
affiliation for yeah effectively right
right okay um so phototropic tendency to
seek the light tropism in this case
means its ability to affect different
tissues in effect there is a constraint
on a natural virus don't infect tissues
that don't help spread the virus so that
you leave the animal as healthy as
possible so it can go around and do the
spreading in this case if you've got you
know animals caged so that they don't
have to be any good at being animals
right they're just cellular environments
then you lift a constraint and the
question is is part of the
large number of tissues that seem to be
negatively impacted by this virus the
result of the fact that it was in a
highly unusual circumstance in which
animals couldn't get away from each
other
if that's what happened then the point
is much of the harm that comes to an
individual who gets sick with this may
be the result of its unnatural origin
and so
in effect all of the explanations that
say look
okay
if it came from a lab we need to know
that so it doesn't happen again but
short of that none of this matters no it
all matters and what you really need are
people who are uh
informed enough and uh insulated from
the incentives that they can actually
have a conversation about how much harm
came to humanity from which errors right
and the errors just continued to
compound
well or you could make the founder of
ecohealth alliance the lead on the
investigation of what the origin of
sarsko v2 was for the trip to china i
mean that seems like there's no conflict
there no you could just tell him that
he's got a new job and his new job is to
find out whether this came from the lab
and i'm sure he would you know his new
job is to see if he's a criminal in a
past life which is to say a current life
this is cool
this is this is next next level uh
criminal investigation where
the people who do the investigation are
the people who are in the best position
to do it by virtue of the fact that they
committed the crime and therefore
knowing they're in nearly complete
possession of the information necessary
to
to prosecute it's beautiful yeah i mean
it's almost meritorious
excellent
excellent well um boy there is a lot
that we
were thinking we might get to today um
and we didn't but uh we will be back
we will be back next week will be
earlier um i will say it's you know you
guys unless you're in portland watching
live right now
we'll have not be having this experience
but it was
so gorgeous in spring like here this
morning and i was outside i came home
and i said to our younger son toby was
15. i said go out like go out on your
unicycle enjoy this because according to
my phone
by three o'clock it's going to be
raining and it's never going to stop and
it's raining now it's it turned
completely gross out there and it feels
it's amazing how you can feel when
you're in a weather
system like this is now what is and it's
part of why the sun for those of us who
like the sun i think that's almost
everyone like oh this is wonderful i
feel good and then as soon as this
happens like
damn well it's it's worth talking about
another time but i actually think that
there's something
just as it is hugely different to write
with a word processor than a typewriter
that we're talking about earlier this
week yeah there's something hugely
different to have seen weather at large
scale by virtue of modern tech
imagine living you know if you if you if
you had never seen a satellite image or
yeah
something and you saw the sun shine the
way it felt like it was going to last
forever yeah and then you know to have
it change so radically is you know
obviously everybody experiences that but
you know we of course know exactly what
that looks like it looks like a system
blowing yeah
and actually i mean this is also kind of
new technology
but um
we've had the opportunity to be in a
couple of different canopy towers in the
amazon uh where um yes by dent of
someone else's hard work you know
pulling
wood and and uh and hardware up a tree
you end up with a platform that you can
climb up to 120 feet up a canopy tree or
so and you can look on thinking of the
one at tepatini in particular where you
can actually look out so you're actually
i think it's in us is it a saba and it's
an emergent tree so you're slightly
above much of the canopy
i can't remember
there are a couple but that one uh i
think it is the same yeah i think it is
anyway you can you can actually look out
over the canopy you're not still i mean
you are in it and you oh the bird life
up there is amazing but you can look and
at some moments you can actually see
from a long way off the weather coming
at you and you know and you know it
starts to taste different like you can
feel the ozone you can feel the
electricity like you can you can you can
feel it viscerally but to also be able
to be up there and see it you're like
i'm about to get really really wet
um
he's announcing that
announcing it yeah incredible um but
it's still not satellite level it's not
it's not that zoomed out um
all right we are going to take
a break um and we'll be back for those
of you listening live in 15 minutes or
less even
with the live q a again you can ask
questions at
www.darkhorsesubmissions.com we'll get
to as many of them as we can
we always take a question
from
that is voted on on the discord server
every week and you can find access to
that that lovely community on our
patreons
if you have logistical questions uh you
can email thedarkhorsemoderator
gmail.com
and
consider reading our book which i've
hidden under a pile of paper it looks
like
and
be good to the ones you love eat good
food and get outside save the masks for
halloween be well everyone
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you